sofiane hace colchas cosiendo algunos
cuadrados azules y verdes la razón de
cuadrados azules a verde se muestra en
el diagrama la tabla muestra el número
de cuadrados azules y verdes que sofía
utilizará en donde sus colchas aquí
puedes ver la tabla de acuerdo con la
razón completa los valores faltantes en
la tabla bueno pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes terminar la tabla
primero pensemos en la razón entre los
cuadrados azules y los verdes observan
que por cada 123 por cada tres cuadrados
azules tienes 1234 55 cuadrados verdes
entonces la razón entre los cuadrados
azules y los verdes serán de 3 a 5
ahora en esta colcha azul sofía tiene 21
cuadrados azules observan es el dato que
nos dan cuántos cuadrados verdes debe de
poner para ir de 3 a 21 lo que tuvimos
que hacer fue multiplicar por siete
multiplicamos por 7 entonces vamos a
hacer lo mismo para los cuadrados verdes
vamos a multiplicar por siete y 5 por 7
es 35 ok 35 cuadrados verdes es decir
para que se conserve la razón
necesitamos multiplicar o dividir
estos números por la misma cantidad
de esta forma seguirás con una razón
equivalente por lo tanto 21 a 35 es la
misma razón que 35
ahora tenemos otra colcha la colcha bm
que en este caso se han cocido 20
cuadrados verdes
y ahora quiero saber cuántos cuadrados
azules tengo que agregar recuerdan lo
que queremos es tener la misma razón
bueno para ir de 5 a 20 lo que hicimos
fue multiplicar por 4 por lo tanto si
multiplicamos el número de cuadrados
verdes por 4 tenemos que hacer lo mismo
para los cuadrados azules y 3 por 4
esto me va a dar 12 así que ya están 12
cuadrados azules por cada 20 cuadrados
verdes es la misma razón que tres
cuadrados azules por cada cinco verdes
bien hagamos otro ejemplo y este nos
dice el siguiente diagrama describen el
número de tazas de pintura sol y roja en
una mezcla
cuál es la razón entre la pintura azul y
la pintura roja en la mezcla escoge una
respuesta buena pausa e inténtalo bien
veamos vamos a tener 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 cuadrados azules déjame
ponerlo 10 barras azules por cada veamos
1 2 3 4 5 6 por cada 6 barras rojas y
esta es una razón de 10 a 6 pero esta no
es la forma más simplificada que podemos
dar porque ambos números son divisibles
entre 2 si dividimos 10 entre 2 voy a
obtener 5 y si divido 6 entre 2 voy a
obtener 3
otra forma de pensarlo es que por cada
cinco tazas de pintura azul vamos a
tener que agregar tres tazas de pintura
roja en la mezcla o si lo vemos en el
diagrama de barras por cada cinco barras
azules tenemos tres barras rojas y lo
podemos ver aquí observa
por cada tres barras rojas tengo cinco
barras azules aquí está de igual manera
que por cada tres tazas de color roja
tengo cinco tazas de color azul así que
seleccionemos la primera opción la
opción de una razón de cinco a tres
perfecto hagamos un último ejemplo
ahora tengo este de cam un autor está
escribiendo e ilustrando un nuevo libro
la razón entre las páginas de texto y
las que tienen ilustraciones se
representa en el diagrama de barras y lo
tengo aquí de acuerdo con la razón cuál
es el número de páginas de texto cuando
hay 22 páginas con ilustraciones bien
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta vamos a ver la razón que
tenemos por cada una dos tres páginas de
texto es de dos páginas de ilustraciones
1 2
por lo tanto tengo una razón de 3 a 2
ahora si tenemos 22 páginas de
ilustraciones 22 páginas de
ilustraciones entonces pasamos de 2 a 22
es decir 2 por 11 es 22 estamos
multiplicando por 11 para obtener el 22
y por lo tanto tenemos que hacer lo
mismo para la cantidad de las páginas de
texto habrá que multiplicarlo por 11
para obtener las páginas de texto que
conserven esta razón 3 por 11 es 33
y ya está así que tres páginas de texto
por cada dos páginas de ilustraciones es
la misma razón que 33 páginas de texto
por cada 22 páginas de ilustraciones
entonces cuál es el número de páginas de
texto cuando hay 22 páginas con
ilustraciones bueno el autor escribe 33
páginas de texto y hemos acabado nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo